depuis hier plus question d'en griller
une tranquillement installé dans son
fauteuil dans un avion d'air france tous
les vols d'air france sont maintenant
non fumeurs avec un petit service en
plus si vous fumez et si vous êtes en
manque pendant le vol et bien l'hôtesse
pourra vous donner un petit comprimé un
substitut de nicotine pour vous apaiser
air france propose même maintenant des
consultations médicales juliette beau et
nathalie gallet dans les avions en
france le service ne sera plus aussi
classique qu'avant au même titre que
plateaux repas aux boissons vous pourrez
obtenir désormais une de ces étranges
petites plaquettes des substituts à la
nicotine
car depuis hier tous les vols long
courrier de la compagnie bannissent
catégoriquement la cigarette
je suis prêt c'est une excellente mesure
en plus autant il est non fumeur sont
quelquefois désert de vis-à-vis des
punis mais les fumeurs n'ont aucun
respect pour les non seulement je suis
fumeuse je fais beaucoup mais je ne suis
jamais dans les avions je trouve ça
c'est normal qu'on ne fume pas dans un
avion sur tous les longs courriers
parce que ça rend fou tout le monde et
que c'est pas normal d'en fumer tout le
monde
cette politique anti tabac air france
l'entamé il ya une dizaine d'années elle
est devenue de plus en plus restrictives
depuis le rapprochement avec des
compagnies américaines et face à
l'évolution générale des mentalités
nous suivons cela la demande générale de
la société des clients et aussi
l'évolution de la très grande majorité
des compagnies et nous ferons la
première alliance nos fumeurs et depuis
septembre une consultation avec un
spécialiste est proposée à tous ceux qui
ont vraiment du mal à se passer d'une
bouffée de cigarette